anywhere in the city I'll tell you the
best public toilet fifty fourth and
sixth sperry rand building 14th floor
morgan apparel mention my name she'll
give you the kid the greatest city in
the world new york new york it's home to
8 million sols a magnet for 52 million
tourists a year and legendre for the
grossest public toilets the side of a
Turkish prison that makes sense since
nobody really owns public toilets
leading to the ultimate tragedy of the
Commons there's a reason the New York
City Shopping glog racked recently
listed 16 of the best in-store private
bathrooms for New Yorkers on the go now
can you imagine a similar list of John's
maintained by Mayor Mike Bloomberg
Spidey team getting top marks are the
bathrooms at upscale accessory store
henri bendel where each stall is the
size of an Upper West Side studio
apartment this tastefully decorated
facility at the half coffee shop half
clothing store saturday surf has
beautifully designed wooden accents
Bergdorf Goodman offers bathroom goers a
delightful combination of fancy beauty
products and moonlighting forget Central
Park the Statue of Liberty in Times
Square what makes New York so great
aren't the public spaces it's the
private ones businesses leave open for
the public to trample whether that means
misusing the books at barnes and noble
surfing the internet at the apple store
or working all day at a brooklyn coffee
shop while nursing a single two-dollar
cuppa Joe more important it's the city's
bookstores coffee shops boutiques and
other businesses that welcome the
full-bladder with open stalls and scrub
toilets
let's hear three flushes for American
capitalism if it weren't for these great
private bathrooms we just walk in and
use we don't be walking around with
their own toilet paper rolls hand soap
and wax paper rim covers for recent TV
I'm Kennedy